fig has been around since since since
the day
time but for me myself I love it because
it's survival of the fittest you know
what I'm saying I'm able to to
experience things that the other person
could never experience being on figuro
figuro has brought me places it's taken
me places and it's hindered me also but
but the the best thing about it is the
money if it's not for the money then
there nothing funny you know what I'm
saying you got to be able to get out
there and get that paper from these
females and that's what they proceive
that's what they do you know my
lifestyle is is not accepted throughout
the world but it's accepted to me and my
vicinity you know what I'm saying and I
just love it I mean each person has
their own Taste of life and my taste of
life is fig Ro I've lived on Figo half
my life I've been around fig half my
life and figo's made my life and and and
the women around here they they they
love me and I love
them it's just a A Mir go around we go
around we go around we go around only
thing I don't like is the
share I'm not in the share what's mine
you know I'm saying if it's mine it's
mine but I can accept the fact if she
chooses somebody else I Let Her Fly Away
I'm there's no guill on fig we don't we
don't we don't take over take advantage
we don't use or abuse we try to help
everyone we can see we can help it's
just it's just a money thing it's a
family thing especially you know we all
stick together we work together we have
money together and and and what's good
about it now is Polie they don't they
don't the police don't bother us that's
what I mean by us because if my brothers
on the street I'm on the street also
wherever my brother is I have to be
there also I have to protect her I'm her
savior I'm her her her Mentor whatever
whatever I need to be and I have to
portray that at all times in order to
keep her or however many I have I just
can't let them run the streets and be
run the streets and be free yeah it's
rules and regulations to everything you
doing and in this game and and the best
part about it is the outcome now that
they the police not really harassing
them nothing the most person I got to
worry about is somebody else trying to
come take them from me that that that
that but that's a part of the game you
win a few you lose a few just according
how many you know what you want out of
life how how did you get started
well I got started at a young age my
mother was in someone in the life
and and and her girlfriends just would
pick me just choose me dressed me you
know it was like it didn't really mean
nothing at first but then when I
realized what was going on I I just got
infatuated with the whole situation I've
never been really ugly person in life I
always handsome young men all my life
and women just enjoyed being around me
buying stuff for me doing things for me
and one thing led to another but then at
the same time now in life I'm 65 I've
never work a damn in my life until I got
64 so so living was been beautiful for
me but now that that that things have
changed times change put it like that
times change people change and and
everything plays out sooner or later so
I had to I have children now and I don't
want necessarily want them to to go the
same route I went but at the same time I
have to let them live their own life but
I have to show them something different
from what I went through in order for
them to have a choice see fig you don't
have a choice it it it grabs you it
loves you so you love it back in return
you know what I'm saying you don't want
to leave Figo cuz if you leave Figo Figo
might leave you and then your money's
gone your broad is gone you ain't got
nothing to show for so this is up and
down scale you know what was the uh the
your
favorite decade or era of of like the
last 40 Years of doing this
well truthfully now
because I'm not really sure how the
situation is going but far as I can see
girls out here doing is legal they're
not taking them to jail they're not do
nothing so we doing sit back stacking
money just stacking stacking stacking
stacking and racking so that's all that
matters right now but back in the day
when it was really a hustle in a bustu
that was a little bit more strenuous
because you had to baild a out you
had to baild the in you know it
was just to things you had to do in
order to keep going but now it's just
you just sit back and relax and bring in
the money I mean it's much easier now
than it was back in the day because
basically it seems like it's
[Music]
legal well I think I think
prostitution legal or
not keeps like rapists from doing what
they would be doing if if it was well
it's not necessar going to keep a rapist
from doing what they're going to do
because if you're a rapist you're a
rapist I'm regardless no but I I think
it there there's some people that would
go off and do something really violently
if it was out of control but the fact
that they can go to Figaro Street and
get something take care of yes get get
taken care of like like that's what back
in the day a lot of girls was was afraid
of because sick there going to be sickos
out there everywhere you go you don't
have to be be you got a sicko wherever
you go but but if sex wasn't so readily
available then yeah available is is more
accessible you know what I'm saying so
that it more easier for the for the for
the customer you know I try to give them
that particular name because trick sound
so I mean well hey that's what they are
but I tell my
girls don't worry about it don't let
them as a trick let as a customer you
supply you have a supply demand and and
they have a supply demand they you
supplying your services they supplying
their money I mean you know when when
you lab a person is a
trick in the back of their head they
really back in the day tricks it it was
just that word would make a person upset
you know what I'm saying but nowadays
hey I mean I've been labeled as a trick
before you know what I'm saying if I
took a of Burger King and bought a
hamburger I was labeled as a trick so
hey to each his own but I mean at the
same
time life is what you make it what what
what are the qualities that you need to
have in order to do that kind do this
kind of work the female of myself you
there's no quality you had want have
that
paper but at the same time you have to
know how to talk to a female you know
I'm saying it's about controlling her
mind and her money you know what I'm
saying and which which
nowadays nowadays is a little different
back in the day because nowadays A
Woman's going want to pay who she wants
to pay she might pay me today and you
tomorrow because who who who her fantasy
of being pay is you know what I'm saying
it's ups and it's down in this game you
know what I'm saying ain't nothing
guaranteed no more you you wake up money
your ho go to somebody else nowaday
whoever's the
flashes is who going to catch the most
females but me myself I'm not I'm not
competing against the next man you know
what I'm saying I'm competing against
time cuz time waste for nobody and soon
later everybody's time is going to run
out so when mine runs out I want to be
set for it to run out in
time how many girls have you had at one
time six six
yeah that's that that's got to get crazy
uh not crazy complicated complicated
because each individual female wants
time like I just said time was for
nobody and in order to give everybody
their time they have to do something to
get their time they have to deserve
their time and at the same time every we
all we're all together at one
time is it purely business or is there a
romantic element to it as well I
mean that that that falls in two places
it's pury business if you don't care
about your but it's romantic if
you care about your you know what
I'm saying like like like me myself and
I love ain't got nothing to do with this
this is this is the financial situation
we're gaining something we're winning
something I I don't I don't expect no
more from her no less from her I'm
saying I expect the same thing from
everybody in order for us all get over
in life you know what I'm saying
you've been in trouble with the
law uh as far as what I'm doing know
other things I've did in life yes but
far because I don't put myself out there
to be
recognized now when I was young I was
out there with the gold streaks in my
hair and the cat like all in Hollywood
but it it sent me back to
Fig because Hollywood is not acceptable
but it was done for it was acceptable
for I'm at home I'm at peace I have to
look over my back and then at the same
time in this
lifestyle I was
rais you don't you don't be jealous of
nobody and you got a lot of jealous
people out there in the world when you
when you're coming up and you're having
things and you have to worry about that
at all times because why because
anything you could do I could do also if
I choose to do it but these people noway
rather sit up and let me do all the work
and then come try to take it from me so
that that that makes it a little hard
when you have to look over your back and
what about the haters and and the
jealous mother out there in the world
today you know what I'm saying but other
than that piece of cake pimp pimp seemed
to be one of the most hated segments of
society yes why do you think that is
because they feel they're not doing
nothing but we the only know this is a
job you're just exploiting women uh I'm
not exploiting no that's that's the
claim but that's they feel I'm doing but
they're exporting theirself you see I do
with a scir on shcking my ass she's
going to be doing it regardless of
whether you're managing her money or not
regardless of who's managing their money
they're going to do that if that's what
they choose to do they're going to do it
at the same time I've had women sit up
and tell me why they doing it in the
movies and they getting paid for why
can't
I and I had to accept that you
know but but but the cold part about the
whole situation is life is not
guaranteed to nobody so you get what you
can get out of life and you run with
it and and and this
lifestyle I've been places I've seen
things I've experienced things that I
feel me myself and I would have never
had experienced working a 9
and5 the people that I met I would feel
haven't met them working a 9 and5 a 9
and5 is good if that's your lifestyle
but if you like have money on a regular
basis 24/7 then this this is the
lifestyle to have but I mean I'm not
here to tell you to tell somebody to go
start pipping I'm just here to tell you
what I've experienced what I've attained
to this lifestyle it's been beautiful
you don't regret oh not not a
second well I take that back I I I
didn't have enough women to get enough
money you know what I'm saying was never
regret
never you uh do you have kids yes I do I
have
oh three girls and three boys and were
you in their lives oh I've been in their
Liv their whole
life bad thing about it both of them
mothers considered
hoes you know what I'm saying and and my
children love the ground I walk on
because their mothers even in the pict
had been in the picture their lives when
I had kids and they were mine I took
took up to the plate and took care of my
taking care of my kids now I have my
oldest now is 18 you have you have kids
that are in in the game oh yeah Co part
about it and my family blames me I have
a son that's out there doing it doing
doing this way colder than I am you
know what I'm saying he's really out
there doing it but he he taught himself
following following his Father's
Footsteps and that that that hurts me
but at the same time I'm proud of it
because he's doing it you know what I'm
saying but I mean I was never a church
house person I never went to work 95 and
all that type of so therefore I
can't expect my kids to do it neither
but I tell them do what you choose to do
my daughter's been on figureo you know
she's on figureo but hey it's life I
don't I don't approve of it but I don't
you know I can't if I'm whatever I'm
done I can't knock the next person from
doing it even if my child I can tell her
what not to do I tell the outcome but I
can't tell her her particular outcome CU
I don't know how it's going how it's
going to out come for them so you know
hey my son he's he he's out there I'm
loving it I'm loving now my
reles they all blame me I mean you can't
blame me blame society where did you
where did you grow up huh I grew up in
South here in South Central yeah yeah
and you remember seeing some of this
kind of stuff going on on the streets
when you were a kid when I was a kid I
was sheltered I was raised by my
grandparents you didn't grow up around
this no but now my mother was in it my
whole lifestyle but I never knew so when
I got about like maybe 17 years old I
went to church 7 days a week one Sunday
I went in the in the in in the front
door of the church house at the back
door of the church house took my
grandma's Cadillac go to my mother's
house and that's my life changed I mean
it was
like watching my grandparents work two
jobs to survive and then I go to my
mother's house and it was like no jobs
and they just having money out of both
pad's legs so it was like got a choice
to make and I choose that choice
the street life was the only life I've
been knowing for my whole life like I
said I'm 65 and I havn't had a job of
day in my life until what last year so
so it it's been it's been good it's been
sweet Are there women that you've had in
your stable that have been standouts
that have been memorable I mean all of
them been stand outs but when they gone
they gone I don't Crow SP milk I try to
bring going
again what kind of girl do you look for
what do you look for in a girl uh uh
whoever can make
money blind CRI crazy it don't matter to
me you know simple as that simple as
that you you you handicap
whatever a ro a ro to play you know what
I'm saying it's always a role to play to
get this paper ain't no ain't no
exception to the
rules and and as far as the the women
that work for you you you see them going
through their ups and downs sometimes
they have drug problems things like that
how do you uh how do you handle that uh
uh drugs is not a problem they're a
problem long I explain to them how is
there a problem you making money to have
what you want to have if you're getting
high of and you're getting high that's
what you choose to do now when you let
the drug get high for you that's hearts
of a different color but long drug
problems I don't consider them having
drug problems they don't consider having
drug problems they there more drug
habits a
dependency but long as you could afford
to get the drug it's not a problem
that's how that's how they look at it so
I make sure they can afford to get what
they want to have where there's no
problems you seen some crazy things oh
yeah I've seen some crazy things I've
experienced some crazy things you
know this lifestyle is crazy tell me a
story or two as far as what just like
some of the crazy stuff you've seen or
people you've
met I mean I I I I I I I
met I've
seen I don't know how I would explain
this I mean I I I've seen the tricks are
got to be crazy I I no tricks are
gullible I I I I'm not
tricks I need a female I need a hoe I
tricked it myself because they were
tricks and then when it start being to
where that I don't consider
a female working a trip
because it's a gift of gabing this
lifestyle we live you know how to
approach a person how to talk to a
person you're going to get over if you
don't know how you're going to get ate
up survival is the fittest you know and
Me Myself and
I I like the
challenge because it might not be a good
thing to say but I set out to manipulate
and communicate at to
everybody if if it benefits me fine if
it doesn't put them down the
line what what is the key to holding on
to a girl there is no key to holding on
to a girl don't let nobody never lie and
tell you that she's yours why you have
her she somebody else when she's gone
because in this particular
game love loves
nobody she's yours one day and then when
the next fly mother come along a little
fly than me got a little more than me
you know I'm saying little more offer
than me sh F off go to him you know so
you accept what you have what you have
when you have it and you run with it you
you don't you don't oh I'm make a house
in a castle you don't you don't do that
no more you can't you can't be for sure
what you got you you accept what you
have today cuz tomorrow's not guaranteed
to you I live for the day but I can make
today who I can catch today it's for the
day cuz tomorrow's not here yet so my
Mel is I stay I don't go to sleep to
12:01
for therefore I'm already here on the
next day when you go to sleep before the
end you might not wake up to see the
next day so I bring the next day in then
I go to
sleep You' been in love before I bring
the next day I don't go to sleep till
12:01 no but have you been in love
before I'm in love now with
myself but love yet where to get
me uh a whole bunch of kids that got no
child support but bun of
kids but I've
been love is
vulnerability that's how I come to feel
about the whole situation because when
you love somebody love is vulnerability
yeah when you love somebody you leaving
yourself open to be hurt so I love what
I
do I love how I
live but as far as an
individual I I love no female per say
individually I love them
all they all can't have the same amount
of time whoever paying paying the most
gets the most time that's how that's how
life is
nowadays how how was the game changed
over the
years oh
well like I
say like figure La for example period
this is legal damn near now look
like uh back in the day you everybody
was going to jail
you have you you couldn't afford to be
out there on the street with him because
you going to go to jail right on with a
per pent charge is when of the worst
charges you can get in society as far as
I'm concerned because that that label
sticks with you forever it's on reg you
a pimp you know what I'm saying and
that's something I never choose to have
I just like pimp things I like to live
pimp way but don't put a don't put a
category on me because I'm not going to
carry that that
luggage but there's nothing you can't
have if you want it there's nothing you
can't have how' you get started in the
game like I said my mother was in this
game and you somebody no just from
observing just seeing that just seeing
that you figured out that you can do it
yourself but I could do it myself yeah
what age uh about 19 I'm 65 now now it's
time to retire pass it on down and
that's what everybody saying oh now your
sons is doing it and they going to take
out where you left off that that's
that's back here but I didn't want to
say it
verly but yeah
yeah my boys they they they I love
them I'm not in love with what they're
doing because I've been there done that
but at the same time I can't knock what
they're doing because I allow them to
see what I was doing so it's not
necessarily their fault not Society
fault just life living life on life's
terms would you prefer that prostitution
was legal of course in more ways than
want
but that would Le other
the like like like the average person
who making money off things for
prostitution to be legal selling drugs
to be legal whatever they consider
illegal a person that's making money off
prefer to be legal you know what I'm
saying but me and myself whatever I
choose to do illegal illegal legal I'm
going do it regardless but it's not what
you do is how you do it you don't put
your out there to get get caught you
don't put out to be labeled then you
don't have nothing to worry about
Jerry what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life uh
well the most important lesson I've
learned so far is to trust
nobody don't don't get caught up with
nobody I mean I hate to say this because
it might be heard but I don't even trust
my ho know I'm saying you trust yourself
and you depend upon yourself and then
when something go wrong you blame
yourself you can't get had to blame
somebody else's f it's always my fault
to Happ because I blame
myself and I trust the man
above CU as long as I'm doing what I'm
doing somebody's approving
it and if he choose me not to do this
need a man above he would take it away
from me so until he takes away from me
and put me behind a desk and give me
something better to do I'mma keep doing
it your good your karma is good thank
you thank you thank you thank you I'm
I'm asking I'm I'm asking your your
karma is good oh yeah
yeah you believe what you're doing is
cool I mean I don't believe what I'm
doing is it's hot I don't believe what
I'm doing is bad I believe I'm doing
what I'm doing to survive I think it's
very misunderstood by most of society oh
yeah but no it's misunderstood by the
people that can't do
it if you think you did it you done it
before you understand you acknowledge it
but the people that can't do it is the
one that's misunderstanding it because
they can't do it so they they believe
it's illegal is Ro against against
reality no if you could do it you'd be
doing the same thing I I think what what
I've learned is I think most of
especially most of White Society comes
from a a world that's so foreign to the
the world you grow up in and these girls
grew up and they cannot understand it
and they just see you as you're just
exploiting these poor females and and
that's not quite the the whole picture
mhm true true and then it's just like
mother told us mama told you don't do
this mama told you don't do that that's
how white Society is if Mama didn't tell
you was all right it's never going to be
all right in White Society but if Mama
tell you it was all right White Society
did it would be all right White Society
I think I think if the if the white
Community made more opportunities for
the black community yes and and shared
their wealth a little bit more then I
think this wouldn't be such a it change
situation it would change the situation
yes yes but the whites don't want to do
that no they want to keep you out here
to if if we wouldn't here it wouldn't be
nothing to talk
about and just be a boring world you
know what I'm saying everybody's doing
good everybody's doing good but you have
to put the bad you have to blame the bad
on somebody so that FS on us Figo I've
been here half my life Figo is just as
good as Hollywood Beverly Hills but you
let the media and everybody tend to Fig
is the bottom of the line F you going
you get robbed you go to F you going get
prostitut going to catch you if you go
to F no uh if I'm not
mistaken put the Coliseum or something
on
figur I'm not far from fig yeah yeah us
Museum on fig a lot of good stuff in
Cali fig is a very interesting street
yes it changes drastically from from
downtown to yes South a yes
so TW is
on I love
it I mean I wouldn't choose to to I
don't plan on dying
here but but I'm going to be here until
I die I don't plan on dying here but I'm
going be here until I die you know what
I'm saying figure speech but at the same
time you always want a little cfort F
I'm more comfortable in fig than I am in
B
Hills cuz I know where I'm at I know who
I'm dealing with bab Hill you got a lot
of people saying to be good and they're
not good but only good to to the point
where they want to be you can't put me
in no no no stereotype on fig fig
figure
all right Dre thank you so much for
sharing your story uhhuh uhhuh anytime
very interesting and good luck with good
luck with whatever you do from here
uhhuh thank
you